okay let's do what some people love and
some people hate which is let's review
new options for the David Pakman show
theme song so the background on this
entire thing well the background is we
have a show that started years ago and
we have a theme song right now our theme
song was created by a great longtime
supporter of the show who goes by the
musical name of curtly jay because of no
reason other than we like to rotate
theme songs over time we say this with
complete complete peace and love we love
Kirtley jay but sometimes we just want
to shake up what the show is sounding
like we have some new options and
eventually we should make this a poll
for now I'm kind of keeping it informal
I have a few new options out and I want
to review the original options that we
have for new David Pakman show theme
songs so first of all here is the song
contemporary American from the artist
known as chousen take a listen to this
[Music]
right that's one possibility so now I'm
just catching you up then we'll get to
the new ones another possibility from
art Flores starts a little slow very
different sound here's a sample of that
[Music]
okay then I've also mentioned that Stu
Brooks basis for Matisyahu and dub trio
has worked with 50 cent Tupac lots of
people friend of the show he has said
use our music if you want it here's a
possibility from the 2004 dubbed REO
album exploring the dangers another
possibility for the theme song alright
some people feeling that the dub trio
option was a little slow and then here's
the new option this is from an artist
called Philo's cult the S at the end of
Philo's is a dollar sign maybe it's
pronounced filos called I'm just not hip
enough to know the right pronunciation
for some of these artists but the song
is called West here's a new entry that's
a possibility take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
alright those are the options so far I
know some people feel very strongly that
they like one in particular some people
said David all of these are absolutely
terrible don't use any of them others
agreeing with Pat that option two is
good but the guitars a little too
distorted some people felt the
distortion was great that's what we've
got so far and if you have submissions
keep sending the men whether it's custom
or something of yours that you're up for
us using will eventually make a poll out
of it and see how people feel